happy birthday harry potter the boy who
lived is celebrating his 40th birthday
on july 31st 2020
and we're celebrating by catching up
with mr potter and his loved ones
to find out exactly what life is like
for them in 2020
discover everything we know about
harry's career his fame
his marriage and his family with special
secrets spilled by none other than jk
rowling
catch up with ron hermione and jenny 2
plus more of your favorite characters
that are still in harry's life in 2020.
promise you'll write this summer both of
you
i won't first up is harry's love life as
we know from the epilogue in harry
potter and the deathly hallows
harry married ginny weasley we get to
see them as a married couple in the 19
years later scene of the final movie
which takes place on september 1st
2017. they definitely look nearly 20
years older right guess that's what
parenthood does to you
of course lots of fans shipped harry and
hermione but harry and ginny lasted the
distance
fast forward 3 years to 2020 and they
are still together
we know this thanks to jk rowling's 2016
stage play harry potter and the cursed
child and we can feel pretty safe in the
assumption that these two lovebirds
married for life
after all jk rowling explained that
harry and ginny are real soulmates
during a book tour q a session at
carnegie hall in october 2007
the author said they're both very strong
and very passionate
that's their connection and they're
remarkable together
but what does harry look like at 40 we
get a good idea
seeing him age to 37 in the 19 years
later scene
round glasses check floppy hair
check yep that's harry alright just a
middle-aged diversion
but jk rowling gave us an even better
idea of how harry's aging
during that same book tour q a session
the author revealed that
she married harry potter what what what
that would be quite the revelation but
in all seriousness what she actually
means is that
she believes her husband neil murray
looks like what harry would look like at
a certain age
when you look at photos of neil in 2007
you can see a resemblance
if only he would swap those rectangular
frames for round glasses
harry and jenny had three kids together
each named after important people in
their lives
their firstborn james sirius potter was
named after harry's father and godfather
ron and hermione are his godparents
their second child was named albus
severus after dumbledore and snape
neville longbottom is his godfather
their third child
lily luna was named after harry's mother
and luna lovegood
there are two high school years between
each child so when we see the family in
2017
albus is starting his first year at
hogwarts james is going into his third
year and lily has to wait another two
years until she can start
we bet ginny could sympathize with her
youngest about the agony of watching
your older brothers head off on
adventures while you're stuck at home
lily did get to hogwarts in the end
though in 2020
lily was seen on platform nine in three
quarters along with the rest of the
family
sitting on her older brother's trolley
we discovered this and everything else
that happens to the family from 2017
onwards thanks to the play harry potter
and the cursed
child we know that james and lily are
sorted into gryffindor house
while albus is a slytherin the place
centers on albus and his friendship with
draco malfoy's son
scorpius of course during the 19 years
later scene we also get to see scorpius
draco and his wife who we later find out
is called astoria green grass
so someone did manage to catch draco's
eye eventually
bad luck there pansy parkinson let's
just see i don't think i see me wasting
my time in
charms class next year as for harry's
best friends
ron and hermione are still much a part
of his life as ever as we see in 19
years later
they married and had two children rose
granger weasley started at hogwarts in
2017 along with albus and hugo granger
weasley followed up two years later in
2019 along with lily
we learned from ron that rose inherited
hermione's brains
we get even more information about rose
in the curse to child play
it sounds like she inherited ron's
quidditch skills too as she gets
selected as chaser for gryffindor's
quidditch team
would you rather have hermione's brains
or ron's quidditch skills huh
it's a tough choice right and no you
can't have both
the granger weasleys are not the only
part of harry's extended family in his
adulthood
we also learn in the epilogue of the
book that harry is godfather to teddy
lupin
teddy left hogwarts in 2017 and spotted
kissing victoire at king's cross station
while the potters and granger weasleys
gather for the hogwarts express
victoire is bill and flo weasley's
eldest daughter and she has two younger
siblings called dominique and louis
as you can see harry is surrounded by
even more loved ones in his adulthood
with all these interlinked families
if you ever wondered whether your
childhood sweetheart could really be the
one
there are plenty of couples in harry
potter that prove that long lasting love
can blossom at high school
in fact practically all of the
characters met their eventual partners
while they were at school you don't
remember anything
from that night but as well as love the
harry potter series contained a lot of
heartbreak too
like harry teddy became an orphan at a
young age after his parents
remus and tongs passed away harry was
involved in helping to raise teddy who
was born in 1998.
in fact j.k rowling revealed to the
today show that teddy was one of the
main reasons why she wanted to write the
epilogue
it was important to her because teddy
was orphaned and she needed to know that
the world was a better place for him
she even started to cry when she wrote
it so the author realized how much he
meant to her
jk rowling also tweeted in september
2015 that
teddy was made head boy at hogwarts the
year that harry's eldest son james
started at the school
as a hufflepuff teddy was disappointed
that james was sorted into gryffindor as
for
muggle relations what about harry's
relationship with dudley in 2020
when a fan asked jk rowling if the two
would ever see each other again she said
harry and dudley would see each other
enough to be on christmas card terms
however they do it out of a sense of
duty and sit in silence so that their
children could see their cousins
we learn more about how harry spends
special times with family and extended
family like teddy in jk rowling's
accounts of the 2014
quidditch world cup finals teddy was
there with victoire as were the potters
the granger weasleys and ron's brother
george he was there with his wife
angelina johnson
former captain of the gryffindor
quidditch team and their children
roxanne and fred
named after george's late twin brother
yep see
the gang really did stick together
doesn't that make your heart burst with
happiness
hello everyone luna lovegood is also
with the group in a live chat on the
bloomsbury website
jk rowling revealed that luna became a
very famous wizarding naturalist who
discovered and classified many new
species of animals
she got married later than harry and the
rest marrying a fellow naturalist to
rolf
the grandson of newt scamander no less
they had twin sons called lorcan and
lysander
neville longbottom who had become the
herbology teacher at hogwarts was seen
sharing a joke with harry at the match
neville married hufflepuff hannah abbott
who became landlady of the leaky
cauldron
it was reported that hannah had
retrained as a healer and applied for
the job of matron at hogwarts
jk rowling wrote as read as skeeter and
as ginny weasley for the world cup
reports
yup rita's still a gossip correspondent
for the daily profit
you wouldn't attempt in your dizziest
daydreams
concerned but harry's wife ginny is also
working for the paper
after the second wizarding war she
became a professional quidditch player
for the holy head
harpies and then she became the senior
quidditch correspondent for the daily
prophet which was her job at the time of
the 2014 quidditch world cup
but by 2020 ginny have been promoted to
the position of sports editor
hermione is also flying high with her
career in 2020 stay tuned for all the
info on that and to learn about harry's
career
but back to that world cup rita skeeter
reported that harry and the rest of
dumbledore's army were given the vip
section of the campsite harry took his
sons james and albus to the players
compound to meet victor crum
who's still the bulgarian seeker rita
claimed that harry
even before he turned 34 had a couple of
threads of silver in his black hair
given his harrowing past we're not
surprised to hear that
in what could have been a foreshadowing
of albus becoming a slytherin
he was the only member of the potter
family to wear brazilian green
the rest wore the red of bulgaria and
bulgaria one
in case you were wondering props to you
viktor krum you have no
business here this tent is for champions
and friends so that's how harry's family
life and social life is going at the age
of 40
but what about his professional life how
did harry's career progress after the
battle of hogwarts
he didn't go back to school to take his
nude exams unlike hermione who finished
her education
instead he joined the reshuffled aurora
department under kingsley shacklebolt
straight away in 1998
aged to 17 in a fan q a as part of her
interview with the today show
jk rowling revealed what harry ron and
hermione were doing for a living
she spilled that harry and ron utterly
revolutionized the aurora department
after the second wizarding war
the author added that harry and ron were
the experts and were leading the way in
recreating the new aurora department
and eventually harry was in fact heading
up that department which is not corrupt
in any way
here he also occasionally returned to
hogwarts to give defense against the
dark arts lectures
as for hermione by 2017 she was pretty
high up in the department for magical
law enforcement
she would have a sound grounding for
that job because of her brain power and
knowledge for how the dark arts operate
so their professional lives were at the
ministry of magic but it's a very new
ministry
they made a new world fast forward to
2020
and what are harry and his two best
friends doing well we learn in the curse
to child play that
harry had become head of the department
of magical law enforcement by the summer
of 2020 so where does that leave
hermione
well by that point hermione had taken
over from kingsley shacklebolt as the
minister of magic
yeah she got the top job as for ron
after working hours as an aurora for two
years
he helped his brother george turn
weasley's wizarding wheezes into a huge
success that sounds a lot less stressful
and a lot more fun which is
perfect for ron unsurprisingly harry's
achievements earned him quite the
accolade
in the live chat on the bloomsbury
website a fan asked
jk rowling if harry and his friends
would ever have their own history on
chocolate frog cards
and the author answered definitely and
ron will describe this as his finest
hour
what do you think harry considers his
finest hour in his 40 years
i've got to finish whatever dumbledore
started
what surprised you most about what harry
potter is up to at 40
which characters do you miss the most
from the harry potter series
be sure to let us know in the comments
and hey hit that subscribe button while
you're here
thanks for watching